this video is about the ridiculous way
we used to calculate pi
for 2 000 years the most successful
method
was painstakingly slow and tedious but
then isaac newton came along and
changed the game you could say he speed
ran pie
and i'm going to show you how he did it
but first
pie with pizzas
cut the crust off a pizza and lay it
across
identical pizzas and you'll find that it
goes across
three and a bit pizzas this is pi
the circumference of a circle is roughly
3.14
times its diameter but pi is also
related to a circle's area
area is just pi r squared but why is it
pi
r squared well cut a pizza into
really thin slices and then form these
slices
into a rectangle now the area of this
rectangle is just
length times width the length of the
rectangle
is half the circumference because
there's half the crust on one side and
half
on the other so the length is pi r
and then the width is just the length of
a piece of pizza which is the radius of
the original
circle so area is pi r times
r area is pi r squared
so the area of a unit circle then is
just pi
keep that in mind because it'll come in
handy later
so what was the ridiculous way we used
to calculate pi
well it's sort of the most obvious way
it's
easy to show that pi must be between
three
and four take a circle and draw a
hexagon inside it with sides of length
one
a regular hexagon can be divided into
six
equilateral triangles so the diameter of
the circle
is two now the perimeter of the hexagon
is six
and the circumference of the circle must
be larger than this
so pi must be greater than six over two
so
pi is greater than three now
draw a square around the circle the
perimeter of the square is
eight which is bigger than the circle's
circumference
so pi must be less than eight over two
so pi is less than four this was
actually known for
thousands of years and then in 250 bc
archimedes improved on the method so
first he starts with the hexagon just
like you did
and then he bisects the hexagon to uh
dodecagon so that's a 12-sided regular
12-sided
shape and he calculates its perimeter
the ratio of that perimeter to the
diameter will be less than pi
he does the same thing for a
circumscribed 12-gun
and finds an upper bound for pi
the calculations now become a lot more
tricky because
he has to extract square roots and
square roots of square roots and
and turn all these into fractions but uh
he works out the 12 gone and then the 24
gone
uh 48 gone and and by the time he gets
to the 96 con he sort of had enough
but he gets in the end he gets pi to
between 3.1408 and 3.1429
so for over 2000 years ago that's not
too bad
yeah that seems like all the precision
you need in pi
right so this goes way beyond precision
for any practical purpose this is now a
matter of uh flexing your muscles you
know this is
this is uh showing off just how much
mathematical power you have
that you can work out a constant like pi
to very high precision
so for the next 2 000 years this is how
everyone carried on
bisecting polygons to dizzying heights
as pi passed through chinese indian
persian and arab mathematicians
each contributed to these bounds along
archimedes line
and in the late 16th century frenchman
francois viet
doubled a dozen more times than
archimedes computing the perimeter of a
polygon with
393 216
sides only to be outdone at the turn of
the 17th century by the dutch
ludov van kerlen he spent 25
years on the effort computing to high
accuracy the perimeter
of a polygon with two to the 62 sides
that is four quintillion 611 quadrillion
686 trillion 18 billion 427 million 387
904 sides what was
the reward for all of that hard work
just
35 correct decimal places of pi
he had these digits inscribed on his
tombstone
20 years later his record was surpassed
by christoph greenberger
who got 38 correct decimal places
but he was the last to do it like this
pretty much
yeah because shortly thereafter we get
sir isaac newton on the scene
and once newton introduces his method
nobody
is bisecting n-gons ever again the year
was 1666 and newton was just 23 years
old
he was quarantining at home due to an
outbreak of bubonic plague
newton was playing around with simple
expressions like one plus
x all squared you can multiply it out
and get one plus two x
plus x squared or what about one plus x
all cubed
well again you can multiply out all the
terms and get one
plus three x plus three x squared plus x
cubed
and you could do the same for one plus x
to the four or one plus x to the five
and so on but newton knew there was a
pattern that allowed him to skip all the
tedious arithmetic and go straight to
the answer
if you look at the numbers in these
equations the coefficients on
x and x squared and so on well they're
actually just the numbers in pascal's
triangle
the power that one plus x was raised to
corresponds to the row of the triangle
right and pascal's triangle is really
easy to make it's something that's been
known
from ancient greeks and indians and
chinese persians a lot of different
cultures
discovered this all you do is whenever
you have a row
you just add the two neighbors and that
gives you the value of
the row below it so that's a really
quick
easy thing you can compute you know the
coefficients for one plus x to the 10
in a second instead of sitting there
doing all the algebra the thing that
fascinated me when i started looking at
those
old documents was how even like i don't
speak those languages
i don't know those number systems and
yet it is
obvious it is clear as day that they are
all
writing down the same thing which today
in the western world we call
pascal's triangle that's the beauty of
mathematics it transcends culture it
transcends
time it transcends humanity it's going
to be around well after we're gone and
and ancient civilizations alien
civilizations will know pascal's
triangle
over time people worked out a general
formula
for the numbers in pascal's triangle so
you can calculate the numbers in any row
without having to calculate all the rows
before it
for any expression 1 plus x to the n it
is equal to
1 plus n times x plus
n times n minus 1 x squared on 2
factorial
plus n times n minus 1 times n minus 2
times
x cubed on 3 factorial and so on
and that's the binomial theorem so
binomial because there's only two terms
one in
x bi is two there's two nomials
and uh theorem is that this is a theorem
that you can rigorously prove
that this formula is exactly what you'll
what you'll see
as the coefficients in pascal's triangle
so
all of this was known in newton's day
already
yeah exactly everybody knew this
everybody saw this formula
and yet nobody thought to do with it the
thing that newton did with it
which is to break the formula the
standard binomial theorem
insists that you apply it only when n is
a positive integer
which makes sense right this whole thing
is about working out one plus
x times itself a certain number of times
but newton says
screw that just apply the theorem i mean
math
is about finding patterns and then
extending them and trying to find out
where they break
so he tries one plus x to the negative
one so that's one over one plus x
what happens if i just blindly plug in n
equals negative 1
for the right hand side of the formula
and what you get is the
terms alternate back and forth plus 1
minus 1
plus 1 minus 1 and so on forever
so that's one minus x the next term will
be a plus
x squared the next term will be a minus
x cubed plus x to the fourth minus x to
the fifth so it's just
alternating series with plus plus and
minus signs as the coefficients
so it becomes an infinite series yeah
that's right if you don't have a
positive integer
the binomial theorem newton's binomial
theorem will give you an infinite sum
but how do you understand that like for
all positive integers it was just a
finite
set of terms and now we've got an
infinite set of terms
yeah so what happens is if you have a
positive integer you remember that
formula the coefficient looks like
n times n minus 1 times n minus 2 and so
on when you get to n minus
n if n is a positive integer you will
eventually get there
and n minus n is 0. so that coefficient
and all the coefficients after
it are all zero and that's why it's just
a finite sum it's a finite triangle
but once you get outside of the triangle
with positive integers
you never hit n minus n because n is not
a positive integer
so you get this infinite series so i
think the big question is
does this actually work does newton's
infinite series
actually give you the value of one over
one plus x
right and it might be nonsense there's
lots of math formulas that break
completely when you do this right
there's
we have rules for a reason but uh we
should always
know the extent to which the rules have
a chance of
working farther if you take that whole
series and you multiply it by one
plus x and you multiply all that out
you'll see all the terms cancel except
that leading one
and so that big series times one plus x
is one in other words that big series is
one over
one plus x that's how newton justified
to himself that it makes sense to
apply the formula where it where it
shouldn't be applicable
so newton is convinced the binomial
theorem works
even for negative values of n
which means there's more to pascal's
triangle
above the zeroth row you could add a
zero
and a one that add to make that first
one
and then that row would continue minus
one plus one
minus one plus one all the way out to
infinity
and you know outside the standard
triangle the implied value
everywhere is zero and this fits with
that
the alternating plus and minus ones add
to make zero
everywhere in the row beneath them
and you can extend the pattern for all
negative
integers either using the binomial
theorem
or just looking at what numbers would
add together to make the numbers
underneath and here's something amazing
if you ignore the negative signs for a
minute these are the exact same numbers
arranged in the same pattern as in the
main triangle
the whole thing has just been rotated
on its side
but newton doesn't stop with the
integers
next he tries fractional powers like
1 plus x to the half so now what does it
mean you take 1 plus x to the one half
well that's the same thing as square
root of 1 plus x and he wants to
understand
does that have the same expansion
putting n equals a half into the
binomial theorem he gets
an infinite series that makes me think
that we could actually
go into pascal's triangle blow it up and
add fractions
in between the rows that we're familiar
with
exactly there's even a continuum of
pascal's triangles between zero and one
there's this you know a continuum of
numbers that you could put in for powers
you can think of each fraction like a
half a quarter
a third as existing in its own plane
where in each plane pairs of numbers add
to make the number
beneath them n doesn't have to be a
positive integer anymore
doesn't have to be a positive integer it
doesn't have to be a negative integer it
doesn't have to be an integer so now
we're going to take n to be a half
and he works this thing out and then he
could do all kinds of things for example
he could work out the square root of 3
very quickly and efficiently
because the square root of 3 we can
write 3 as 4 minus 1
and if we pull out a 4 then we get a
square root of 4 which is just 2
times the square root of 1 minus a
quarter
if you put in minus a quarter for x in
this series you'll get a very rapidly
converging
series expansion that will quickly give
you
square root of three to high accuracy
now newton is particularly interested in
n equals a half because the equation for
a unit circle is
x squared plus y squared equals one and
if you solve for
y well the top part of the circle is
equal to
1 minus x squared to the half this is
basically the same expression he's been
looking at
he just has to replace x by minus x
squared
which adds in some minus signs and
doubles the power of x
on each term but now he's got an
equation for a circle
where each term is just a rational
number times
x raised to some power now we have
two different ways of representing the
same thing and whenever you have
something like that
magic is about to happen fireworks about
is about to go off but how does he use
this to calculate pi
well luckily for us he had just invented
calculus or what he called the theory of
flexions
he realizes that if you integrate under
that curve as x goes from zero to one
you're getting the area under the curve
which is a quarter circle
and he knows that the area of a unit
circle
is exactly pi r squared except r is one
so the area is pi
and we want just a quarter so the area
is pi over four
on the other side he has this nice
series and he knows how to integrate
x2 some power you just increase each
power of x by one
and divide by the new power and now you
have an infinite series of terms
which just involve simple arithmetic
with fractions
you put in x equals one and you can
calculate pi
to an arbitrarily high precision
but newton goes even further adding one
final tweak
a not good math paper has zero ideas
it's just pushing through things that
everybody already knows but nobody
bothered to do
then there are good math papers that
have like one new idea that's like
really shockingly new
newton's on new idea number four at this
point and he's about to have new idea
number five
a new idea number five is instead of
integrating from zero to one
he's going to integrate just from zero
to a half you know when you have an
infinite series you want the terms to
decrease
in size as fast as possible that way you
don't have to calculate as many of them
to get a pretty good answer
and newton sees if he integrates not
from 0 to one but from
zero to a half then when he subs in a
half for x
each term will shrink in size by an
additional factor
of x squared which in this case is a
quarter
but if you only integrate to a half what
is the area
under the curve that you're computing
well it is
this part of a circle which you can
break into a
30 degree sector of the circle which has
an area of pi
on twelve plus a right triangle with a
base of a half
and a height of root three on two
so that integral should come out to this
expression and rearranging for pi
you get the following now if you
evaluate
only the first five terms you get pi
equals
3.14161
that's off by just two parts in a
hundred thousand
and to match the computational power of
van curlin's four
quintillion sided polygon you would only
need to compute
50 terms in newton's series what before
it took
years now would take only days
so no one was bisecting polygons to find
pie
ever again why would you yeah do you do
all that work and somebody comes along
and beats you in a second
it's sort of like uh you know once once
someone builds a crane
and then somebody else is still climbing
up on a ladder to put a brick on a house
like that's just not how you build
houses anymore we have new technology
are you out of your mind you're gonna
you know we're gonna build a hundred
story house you're gonna build a
five-story thing that's gonna fall over
you see it in new york city you see
literally where technology
came along there's like rows and rows of
five-story buildings
and all of a sudden here's a 20-story
and here's a 30-story and here's a
90-story
so it's all about who has the technology
for me this is a story about how the
obvious way of doing things is
not always the best way and that it's
often a good idea to play around with
patterns and push them beyond the bounds
where you expect them to work because a
little bit of insight in mathematics
can go a very long way
hey this video was sponsored by
brilliant a website with
interactive courses and quizzes that let
you dive deep into the topics like the
ones i've shown in this video
calculus neural networks programming in
python
they've got you covered now i sometimes
get asked why i don't get into the nitty
gritty detail or
solve numerical problems in my videos
and the answer is
because i don't think a video is the
best way to learn those skills
the best way is to engage yourself in
problem solving like you can
on brilliant i love the way they
scaffold you through a topic
building your understanding and your
confidence as you go and as someone
with a phd in science education i can
say
this is the only real way to learn you
have to be a little uncomfortable to
gain
understanding when i do these quizzes i
find that my brain
is really working so i can guarantee
that whatever level of education you're
at
brilliant will have something for you
it's the perfect compliment to watching
fun educational videos
and for viewers of this channel
brilliant are offering 20 off an annual
subscription to the first
314 or pi hundred people to sign up
just go to brilliant.org veritasium i
will put that link down in the
description
so i want to thank brilliant for
supporting veritasium and i want to
thank you
for watching